you  before we go a remarkable show of  support for victims of 9/11 and those  who serve our country every Tuesday  since September 11th 2001 joanne elaine  and carmen have stood on Main Street in  Freeport Maine for exactly one hour they  proudly waved American flags to honor  those who risked their lives and those  who died but at 74 77 and 83 years old  they've decided this morning will be  their last vigil we made this our life  for 18 years and I have no no regrets  we'd do it again and if I was younger I  keep doing it the women have stood for a  total of 960 three hours they told our  Portland Maine affiliate WGME they'll  continue to volunteer in other ways  that'll do it for us we'll see you  tomorrow take it easy bye-bye